[Music]
guy fieri is cable tv's highest paid
chef
pulling in an estimated 26 million
dollars a year
fieri was born sans the frosted tips in
columbus ohio in 1968
but was raised in ferndale a town in
humboldt county california
his parents were veggie loving hippies
managers at a western clothing store
when guy was 10 he got his first
entrepreneurial taste of the food
business
he created the awesome pretzel cart that
he would take to fairs and rodeos where
hungry crowds would devour his soft
pretzels
as he got older he continued to work in
the food and beverage industry
paying his dues as a dishwasher for a
mexican restaurant
he saved up enough money to become an
exchange student in chantilly france his
junior year of high school
we're guessing he consumed a healthy
amount of baguettes and bree there
because he continued to follow his
passion for food after graduation
he studied hospitality management at un
las vegas
and managed a few restaurants before
finally opening his first one in 2006
johnny garlic's in santa rosa california
hi i'm guy petty and welcome
around the same time he opened that he
sent in an audition tape to be a
contestant on the next food network star
and went on to win the whole thing
securing him his first show
back then food network's audience was
mostly middle-aged females
and the network hoped guy fieri's huge
personality would draw in more male
viewers
flames in greece brought in the dudes
and when diners drive-ins and dives
premiered in 2006
guy joined the elite club of celebrity
chefs
he wasn't a snobby chef screaming at
people he was a regular guy that ate
burgers and dive bars
and america ate that up guy was a full
on character
and an instant magnet for memes the
internet went to work creating a guy
fieri meme for almost anything which
only made him more famous
[Music]
but the network could have never
imagined the magnitude of the show's
success
the laid-back dude had a magical draw
his fame led to guy fieri cookbooks
the guy fieri roadshow and guy fieri
salsa
since then he's hosted more than 14
series on food network
and triple d is still on the air more
than 15 years later
this is where things go off the rails
right here folks diners drive-ins and
dives generated more than 230 million
dollars in ad revenue in just the last
year
and guy recently signed a contract with
food network which will pay out 80
million
over three years a 50 million dollar
raise from his prior agreement
his name is attached to 80 kitchens
worldwide and he has a delivery only
business
flavor town kitchen as well as a new
chain the chicken guy
not to mention santo tequila which he
owns with former van halen singer sammy
hagar
and while he's not doing all of that
fieri and his family make time to give
back
to the community to restaurants to the
troops and more
all in all guy is a pretty big deal
[Music]